new york city is home to tens of
thousands of ukrainians the most of any
city in the united states during world
war ii many settled in a neighborhood
that is now known as little ukraine
today many businesses there are showing
their support for the ukrainian cause
that includes the restaurant foselka
which is popular among diners for its
authentic eastern european menu
we met with second and third generation
owners tom and jason burchard who say
they are finding ways to give back
i've been coming to this place
since it was a hole in the wall many
years ago in manhattan's east village
veselka is serving up traditional
ukrainian food i love the pierogies with
the side of hope i came to support
ukraine
and great food i've lived here for 50
years and it's always been a
significantly ukrainian neighborhood so
of course we're all in support it's been
kind of extraordinary to see every day
all throughout the day
lines of new yorkers waiting to show
that solidarity it's just been amazing
and i'm very
thankful for that jason burchard is the
third generation owner of the celca and
about 40 percent of the staff here is
from ukraine they're in a state of shock
it's a miracle that they come to work
but they do so at a loyalty to the
business and the loyalty to their
co-workers there must be some harrowing
stories of family members back home one
of my line cooks who grew up with four
of his best buddies they've all passed
in the first four days i have others
that are have parents that are still in
kiev and sleeping in the basements or
you know they've now moved into subway
tunnels grandmas are making molotov
cocktails
i mean it's a different time but what
really hasn't changed is basilica and
the food that you provide and the
comfort that that brings the selka
opened as a small storefront in 1954
when the area was known as little
ukraine your father's father-in-law who
opened this restaurant 68 years ago
you still have his photo there my
grandfather was a ukrainian immigrant he
moved here in the late 1940s escaping
russian oppression he always believed in
a free and independent ukraine
unfortunately never survived to see a
free ukraine i hope he would be proud to
know that we're still carrying on the
tradition part of that tradition is the
ukrainian fair you can find on the menu
the pierogi are wonderful
royal different pierogi wonderful yeah 5
000 pierogies are made from scratch
daily by ukrainian cooks in the
restaurant's basement many of them with
family back home watching the news while
they work five thousand pierogies a day
how many gallons of borscht do you think
you go through since the start of the
war
until yesterday we've sold a thousand
gallons of borscht
that's eight thousand bowls
uh yeah it's a lot wow
burchard's dad tom joined us for a bowl
of borscht a dish many ukrainians
consider a symbol of unity definitely
better to eat that with a black shirt
than a white shirt
because once you get it on your shirt it
doesn't come out
this is loving a bowl it's been an
overwhelming outpouring of love
literally and um
i think people really
relate to borscht and what's happening
abroad there's a saying i guess in
ukrainian it's much lower smackdown
you know what's interesting i don't like
beets
this is the only thing
that i will consume that has beets in it
and i can't tell you how many times i've
heard that one hundred percent of the
restaurant's borch sales are going to
humanitarian aid in ukraine what you'd
want people to know
about what this place means
not just to you
to your family but to new yorkers
to the community and now to
your staff that has family members who
are suffering feel free to
consider this your
second dining room we'd be glad to cook
for you welcome you and if you're
hurting and you need um companionship
or a company
you know please come customer
of 50 years
been coming here customer of 50 years
and he
often witnesses people greeting each
other who haven't seen each other
here you know that they meet here for a
meal and
you know other places might be a
handshake or you know or but
constantly sees
love hugs and just emotions that you
wouldn't normally see and he really said
you know what you really should pride
yourself of not only
serving good food but you're a place of
connection and
of love some days get hard and long and
you're wondering if you're doing this
for the right reason but when you hear
stories like that it just pulls at your
heart i'm more happy
happy to carry the tradition
so you may have noticed that jason and i
are wearing matching shirts it's a
traditional ukrainian embroidered shirt
called i'm going to mess this up i
apologize vichy vanka vichy vancouver
ivanka all right
it is worn as a symbol of pride and
jason gave it to me when i came into the
store he wanted he asked me to wear it
uh with him in solidarity it's a
beautiful shirt and it has the added
benefit of uh absorbing the stain that's
what father said i like jason and his
dad together dad looks really good they
uh they are incr it was an incredibly
interesting conversation and what really
struck me is uh the patriarch left
ukraine to escape russian oppression he
came here to united states he was a
refugee yeah that's what we're talking
about now in 2022 he was a refugee here
and found the american dream and dreamed
of a free and liberated ukraine he never
lived to see it and now here in 2022
ukrainians are fleeing
i love that you shot that piece in the
restaurant with all the noise you know
normally on a shoot it's like don't talk
don't talk i love that you shot it that
way also borsch i didn't know that it
was beets i love these is it like a beet
soup it's a beet soup with chicken stock
as you heard me say i hate beats it is
like number one i know you don't like a
lion you don't like him and either and
yet i love borscht i love boring in the
long lines it looks like nobody really
minds waiting in that line yeah there's
always a long line out there and i bet
you half the staff here have been there
at two o'clock in the morning because
it's open 24 hours they're so convenient
yeah it is over 24 hours uh no comment
no
means rainbow oh nice
no comment on the late night yes thank
you very much